Oh
you
we all know we're Friday nights are like
we've got to be by the book tonight you
don't have a customer I want you to
clean clean clean let's get to work
I have a woman here employees took money
out of her purse
yeah a young lady works at the register
about 19 years old blonde Vicki come
with me I swear I didn't take anything I
don't know what's going on here I'm just
trying to do my job
calm down for me okay you don't realize
what kind of trouble you're in
we need to find the money but I'll need
your help so I can get down there we
really have two choices here he's saying
you'll have to take you to jail or what
we could do is to have you strip surger
right now it's true the search in here
No
is this okay to be Dylan of course
you're making a really difficult
situation run very smoothly I'm just
trying to do my job I didn't do anything
I'm gonna need you to address me as sir
understand yeah listen to me sir this
behavior will not be tolerated what the
hell is you doing back there
I did a bad thing that man's eyes to
look to things that ain't right
now please stop talking
you're almost like a real cop I'll do
everything you know that you need